James Hinchcliffe and Sharna Burgess are
back together on the ballroom floor as
lori hernandez mourns the death of her
grandmother and another couple says
goodbye to the ballroom on monday night
semi-finals episode of Dancing with the
Stars it was revealed
Lori's grandmother had died after a
heartwarming pre-taped package had been
set to air this week hi Lauren
this is grandma I'm very very proud of
you mamita continue doing the way you
wanted fantastic okay mama
the 16 year old Olympian pushed on in
honor of her late grandmother and
performed a beautiful Foxtrot with her
pro partner Val Chmerkovskiy lori was
visibly crying during the emotional
performance
and the two received a well-deserved
perfect score I feel ready to come back
and give it my everything and so I'm not
trying to hold back just like Lori and
Val Sharna and James definitely didn't
hold back performing an epic Argentine
tango
after the 29 year old race car drivers
pro partner injured herself and was
unable to dance with him for over two
weeks with James story he came back from
an injury and hopefully this week is the
same for us that I come back from an
injury and we end up better than ever
that they did the two almost got a
perfect score and Sharna was blindfolded
during the entire dance
James even busted out a handstand on a
chair to finish their amazing
performance hands down you are the best
male dancer we've ever had on this show
both Lori and James will go on to
compete in next week's finals in hopes
of winning the Mirrorball trophy but
Tara Jolie and partner Sasha Farber who
received two perfect scores of the night
will not the couple leaving right now
Tara and Sasha
you